Fue precisamente esta represión política y social,
sumada a décadas de colonialismo
y mala educación
lo que erosionó lentamente el significado de la escritura árabe en la región.
Todos estos países solían usar el árabe.
Ahora son solo los verdes y los azules.
En términos simples,
la escritura árabe está muriendo.
En los países árabes postcoloniales
que funcionan en un mundo cada vez más globalizado
es una creciente preocupación
que cada vez menos gente se comunica con escritura árabe.
Mientras hacía mi maestría en Italia, me di cuenta de que extrañaba el árabe.
Extrañaba ver las letras,
digerir su significado.
Un día entré a una de las bibliotecas más grandes de Italia
buscando un libro en árabe.
Me sorprendió que tuvieran esto
en la categoría de "Libros árabes y de Medio Oriente".
(Risas)
Miedo, terrorismo y destrucción.
Ona palabra: ISIS.
Me dolió en el alma
que en el mundo nos vieran así,
aun desde un punto de vista literario.
Me pregunté: ¿qué pasó con los escritores de fama mundial
como Naguib Mahfuz, Khalil Gibran?
¿O los poetas icónicos como Mutanabbi, Nizar Qabbani?
Piensen en esto.
El producto cultural de toda una región
tan rica y tan diversa como esta
se ha dejado de lado,
o incluso ignorado por completo.
El producto cultural de toda una región
no tiene la posibilidad de marcar un impacto importante
en los medios a nivel mundial y en el discurso social de actualidad.
Y después me acordé de mi creencia número uno:
el diseño puede cambiar el mundo.
Solo hace falta que alguien le dé una ojeada a tu trabajo,
sienta algo, conecte.
Entonces empecé.
Pensé, ¿cómo puedo hacer que el mundo deje de vernos como el mal,
como los terroristas del planeta,
y empiece a vernos como iguales,
como humanos?
¿Cómo puedo salvar y honrar la escritura árabe
y compartirla con otras personas, con otras culturas?
Y ahí se me ocurrió:
¿Por qué no combinar los dos símbolos más significativos
de la inocencia y la identidad árabe?
Tal vez así la gente podría notarlo.
¿Qué puede ser más puro, inocente y divertido que los LEGO?
Es un juguete universal.
Juegas con ellos, construyes con ellos,
y con ellos te imaginas infinitas posibilidades.
Mi momento de inspiración llegó en forma de solución bilingüe para enseñar árabe,
porque la comunicación efectiva y la educación hacen posible
una mayor tolerancia en las comunidades.
Sin embargo, la escritura árabe y latina no solo representan mundos diferentes
sino que crean dificultades técnicas
para las comunidades orientales y occidentales
todos los días.
El alfabeto árabe y el latino difieren por muchas razones;
aquí hay algunas de las principales.
Sí, los dos tienen trazos ascendentes y descendentes,
pero tienen líneas de base completamente diferentes.
El árabe tiende a ser más caligráfico
y la conectividad es importante porque las letras deben estar mayormente unidas
para poder articular una palabra.
También usa un sistema de puntuación y diacríticos totalmente distintos.
Pero, más importante aún,
el árabe no tiene mayúsculas.
En cambio, las letras tienen cuatro formas distintas:
inicial, media, aislada y final.
Quiero presentar el idioma árabe a los jóvenes, a los extranjeros,
pero sobre todo quiero ayudar a los refugiados a integrarse
en las sociedades que los reciben,
a través de un sistema de aprendizaje bilingüe,
un flujo de comunicación bidireccional.
Lo llamé "Let's play".
La idea es simplemente crear
una manera divertida y atractiva de aprender árabe estándar moderno
usando LEGO.
Estas son las dos palabras: "Let's Play".
Cada barra de color marca una letra árabe.
Como ven, para cada letra se explica la forma, el sonido
y ejemplos de uso de la palabra,
además del equivalente en alfabeto latino.
El set completo forma un entretenido libro de bolsillo
con las 29 letras árabes en las cuatro formas diferentes,
más un diccionario de 400 palabras.
La página se ve así.
Tiene la letra, la transliteración en escritura latina,
y una descripción debajo.
Les explico el proceso.
Primero armé las letras en mi diminuto estudio, en Florencia.
Fotografié cada letra por separado,
y luego retoqué cada una y elegí el color de fondo
y los tipos de letra.
Y así terminé el set de letras completo.
que son 29 letras por cuatro formas diferentes.
O sea, 116 letras en solo una semana.
Creo que la información debería y puede ser divertida y portátil.
Este libro es el producto terminado,
que algún día voy a publicar
y traducir a la mayor cantidad de idiomas posibles
para que enseñar y aprender árabe sea divertido, fácil y accesible
en todo el mundo.
Con este libro, espero salvar el futuro de la hermosa escritura de mi país.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Trabajar en este proyecto fue como una forma de meditación visual,
como una danza sufí,
una plegaria para un planeta mejor.
Un solo set de bloques dio a luz a dos idiomas.
LEGO es solo una metáfora.
Y dado que todos estamos hechos de los mismos bloques,
me imagino un futuro
donde se desmoronan las barreras
entre las personas.
Entonces, no importa cuán feo sea el mundo que nos rodea,
o cuántos libros desalentadores sobre ISIS, el grupo terrorista,
no Isis, la antigua diosa egipcia,
sigan publicándose,
yo voy a seguir construyendo un mundo de colores.
Shukran, que quiere decir "gracias".
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Muchas gracias.
Gracias.